aprovechó esta oportunidad entonces para
darles a conocer Cuál es su hoja de ruta
para estos próximos 100 días como él lo
espera para poder relanzar las
negociaciones para discutir sobre todo
con sobre ese plan de la vida en el en
el trabajo mejorar las condiciones de
trabajo mejorar también los salarios los
empleos la reconversión entre otras
muchas cosas pero lo cierto Es que a la
salida de esta reunión varios de los
presidentes de estos sindicatos en
particular del medef que es el sindicato
más importante el sindicato patronal más
importante eh dijo Okay entendimos lo
que el presidente dijo pero así no
quiere digamos apresurar las cosas cree
que va a tomar mucho más tiempo mucho
más que cien días de volver a retomar
las negociaciones por todo lo que ha
venido pues sucediendo en el país desde
el comienzo del año cuando se presentó
el texto de de la Reforma pensional
ellos creen que eso va a tomar mucho más
meses y mucho más que ese final de año
que digamos fue Digamos como el
ultimátum un poco En todo caso esa línea
de tiempo que Fi hoy el presidente
macron Para hablar de todos estos temas
respecto al trabajo Que esa va a ser
ahora sus digamos su nuevo caballo de
batalla por los próximos meses en todo
caso como les decía por ahora Pues los
sindicatos Patronales creen que la
situación va a estar difícil para las
negociaciones y en todo caso también
esta hoja de ruta Pues será Elizabeth
Von la primera ministra la que presente
finalmente Los ejes principales de todo
esto la próxima semana en consejo de
ministros la primera ministra que por
ahora pues se le dan digamos un tiempo
un poco más de respiro para poder pues
eh mantener digamos el gobierno pero lo
cierto Es que muchos consideran algunos
analistas algunos expertos consideran
que Elizabeth está perdiendo de alguna
manera pues eh el apoyo de Manuel macan
Así que digamos tendrá hasta el próximo
14 de Julio para ver si las cosas van a
funcionar o no y es posible que si en
caso de que estas cosas pues no no
funcionen y de que no haya de nuevo los
sindicatos en la mesa de negociación
pues Elizabeth pueda salir del gobierno